Hello psych Tagore's we just want to take the time to thank you for all your kind support. We are a team of dedicated
Passionate and hard-working individuals who come together every day with one goal in mind
We want to make psychology come alive for you
We are self-funded and recently launched our patreon if you enjoy the work we do and find it meaningful
Please stick around until the end of the video for
Information on how to get more involved with us and all the cool rewards you can get from us. We hope you enjoy this video
Anxiety isn't fun for anyone
We all know what it's like to feel our stomach do flips or panic over things. We feel we have no control over
Some of us soak our clothes with sweat before a job interview or a presentation
Others have trouble forming words leaving them tongue-tied. These are our physical reactions to stress
Here are six signs. You might have anxiety and not even know it
one
Chronic headaches, if you have throbbing head pain, that won't stop coming back no matter what you do to treat it
Then you may be suffering from an anxiety disorder or at the very least chronic stress
Constant headaches and migraines are common for people who suffer from chronic anxiety
According to the American migraine foundation over fifty percent of those who have migraines also have anxiety
Don't worry
If this sounds like you there are a number of treatment options available
if over-the-counter pain relief doesn't work for you, you might benefit from anti-anxiety medication or cognitive therapy to
excessive bathroom use
Do you often need to use the bathroom before major exams or large social events?
One study in 2011 revealed a strong correlation between a heightened need to urinate and anxiety
Kyle Staller MD states that stress also causes irregularity in our bowel movements
The nervous butterflies in your stomach are actually spasms in your intestinal tract, which can speed up the digestion process and give you diarrhea
Sometimes the spasms only occur in one area of your system leaving a blockage in another this can lead to constipation
three
Muscle tension ever feels sore in your neck or back or catch yourself clenching your jaw
That body stiffness is most likely a product of stress
Body tension can be so long-lasting that many people actually become used to their problem areas
Don't normalize tension pain is your body's Way of telling you to de-stress
Loosen your muscles with regular exercise
Activities like jogging yoga or even a brisk walk can help to reduce muscle stiffness
good habits
Like regular stretching and meditation also work wonders on the body
if you experience more severe muscle tension, you can invest in visiting a licensed masseuse every now and then for
perfectionism
There's nothing wrong with striving to do the best that you can
But there is a difference between doing your best and trying to be the best
Although it's useful to pay attention to detail being perfect is
Impossible and can bring stress to anyone
If you are someone who needs perfect outcomes ranging from work projects to planning the perfect relaxation day
You might be doing more harm to yourself than good
Psychologists sure in more links these behaviors to anxiety, which is related to our obsession over control and fear of failure
For more information on similar behavior, check out our video 13 things people don't realize you do because of your anxiety
Trust issues. Do you often find yourself feeling threatened or intimidated when you meet new people?
Do you feel this despite all your other friends liking them your perception of events? Like this may be affected by anxiety a
2016 study shows that people with anxiety are less able to differentiate between safe and negative situations
One may believe they are simply being smart by keeping their guard up to protect themselves from possible social threats
But this wall stems more from a fear of being vulnerable and forming connections
Nail biting biting or picking your nails may seem just like a regular habit
It gives you something to do to keep your mouth and hands busy
Some people don't even realize they are doing it until someone else points it out
But nail biting is not always just to have it for many. It is a reaction to stress and anxiety
People often bite their nails in an attempt to relieve tension
there are other common tics and habits that people hold - as well such as hair or eyebrow pulling
Itching a specific area of the body and foot-tapping just to name a few
Do you experience any of these signs, please? Share your thoughts with us below
Also, don't forget to subscribe for more content from psych to go and check out our patreon
we started it because we want to go into a bigger platform that reaches more people who were in need of help with your
contribution
You can receive our psi pendant t-shirt issues of our magazine and many more membership benefits
Your funding will help us produce quality script writing voiceovers and animation that makes our content both entertaining and educational
We want to make sure our community members get the best and only the best. Thanks for watching